-C'est quoi Internet ?
-Un système informatique
de communication.
C'est les autoroutes de l'info.
-Il est intelligent, mon copain.
-Des boîtes d'intérim ?
La publicité ?
-Un programme qui permet
de savoir un peu tout.
-C'est le nettoyage.
-J'ignore ce que ça signifie.
-"Inter" quoi ?
-C'est comme un énorme Minitel
qui donne plein d'informations..
..avec tous les pays.
-"Internet" ?
-Oui.
-Ben...
[Elle rit.]
Je ne sais pas.
-J'ai cru comprendre que
ça un rapport avec l'informatique,
..qui a de l'info qui circule,
..et qui faut un ordinateur
pour y accéder.
-J'ai pas le temps,
j'ai rendez-vous.
-Internet, c'est quoi ?
-Je ne sais pas.
-Vous allez chez le coiffeur ?
-Oui.
Là, c'est à refaire,
c'est loupé.
-Mais non !
-Si, si !